Ich bin die Dienstabendärztin auf der Station.
Ich möchte jetzt noch ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen für ihre Person.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Peter Stern.
Peter?
Stern.
Mond und Stern.
Stern, okay.
Herr Schütten, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 45 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
1777.
Okay, und wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 185 groß und wiege 78 Kilogramm.
Okay, Herr Schütten, was haben Sie zu uns beschwert?
Ich bin heute Morgen mit dem Fahrrad gefahren.
Das war, heute hat es ja auch geregnet.
Beim Regen bin ich mit dem Fahrrad um die Kurve gefahren
und bin ausgerutscht und auf die rechte Seite gefallen.
Seitdem tut mir meine Schulterregion weh.
Ich kann meinen Arm nicht richtig bewegen.
Ich habe Schmerzen.
Wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden habe,
beim Fahrradfahren haben Sie sich hingefallen
und auf die rechte Seite.
Auf die rechte Seite hingefallen.
Und wo sind die Schmerzen am stärksten?
Ich würde sagen oben an meiner Schultergelängsregion.
Rechte Seite.
Schultergelängsbereich.
Kann ich nicht genau sagen, es tut mir überall weh.
Strahlen und Schmerzen irgendwo hinauf?
Ja, irgendwie Strahlen, die ich sagen würde,
entweder in meiner Halsfirmen-Säule aus
oder in meinem Schultergelängsbereich irgendwo dort.
Es ist so ein Schmerz, kann ich dich beschreiben.
Es tut stark weh.
Wenn ich nichts mache, geht es,
aber wenn ich meinen Arm hochheben möchte, tut es weh.
Beim Hochheben.
Ich nicht, weil es stark weh tut.
Sie haben Bewegung einschränken.
Genau, in meiner rechten oberen Extremität,
also in meiner rechten Arm.
Und haben Sie beim Erreiten beim Unfall Helm getragen?
Ja, hatte ich kurz vorhin getragen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie verloren?
Nein, ich kann mich alles genau erinnern.
Und vor dem Unfall war es Ihnen schwindig?
Nein, war es nicht.
Ich habe nur die Kontrolle verloren, das ist ausgerutscht
und bin hingestürzt.
Ich wollte nach rechts, wie war das nochmal?
Ich wollte nach rechts abliegen und bin auf die rechte Seite gefallen.
Okay, Herr Stern.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen,
wenn es ein leichter Schmerz ist,
dann ist es ein unerträglicher Schmerz.
Ich würde sagen sieben, sechs oder sieben zwischen sechs, sieben.
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen bis Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Ja, wenn ich nicht bewege, dann geht es.
Aber wenn ich bewege, ist es schlimm.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie auch Luftnot?
Artenprobleme Luftnot habe ich nicht, nein.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Schürfhunde abschürfungen?
Ja, ich habe Schürfhunde einmal in meinem rechten Hohlhand,
in einem Flasche, am rechten oder an meinem rechten Knie,
habe ich auch eine Schürfhunde.
Ist Ihr ein oder ein geschwollener?
Nein, ich kann gut laufen.
Das ist nur eine Schürfhunde, ich habe da keine Schmerzen.
Nur die Wunde brennt ein bisschen, wenn ich mein Knie bewege.
Ich kann laufen, auch meine Hand kann ich gut bewegen.
Haben Sie auch Ihr Kopf verletzt?
Nein, mein Helm hat auch nichts bekommen,
mein Helm ist auch in Ordnung sozusagen.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass ich mit meinem Kopf irgendwo draufgekommen bin.
Aber ich habe dir Gott sei Dank.
Gott sei Dank.
Wie sind Sie hierhergekommen?
Wie bin ich hierhergekommen?
Mit dem Krankenwagen.
Ja, genau.
Da hat jemand einen Krankenwagen Bescheid gesagt
und dieses RTV hat mich hierhergebracht.
Okay, Herr Stamm,
haben Sie auch taufalst gefühlt,
bei Ihnen in Ihren Händen oder Arm?
Nein, ich habe in den rechten Arm kein Taupaz gefühlt.
Und auch mein Knie verletzt hat sich auch
und auch in den Beinen habe ich auch kein Taupaz gefühlt.
Und haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihnen Übel?
Übelkeit habe ich auch nicht, nein.
Appetit ist normal.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit stark ab oder zu genommen ungewöhnlich?
Ungewöhnlich nein.
Das ist mir stabil, mein Gewicht.
Herr Stamm,
haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte, wie Brutordruck,
Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, ich nehme seit zwei Jahren
Medikamente ein wegen Herz-Rhythmestörung.
Seit zwei Jahren.
Ein Medikament nehme ich ein,
Entschuldigung, nicht Medikamente.
Wieso Prolohle nehme ich ein?
Im welche Dosierung?
Das ist fünf Milligramm.
Einmal am Tag, morgens.
Haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Wurden Sie schon eine Operiert?
Ja, an Blinda, der war zehn Jahre alt.
Okay.
Beageringen Sie auch irgendwelche Medikamente?
Oder Lebensmittel?
Ja, haben Sie allegieren?
Ja.
Ist noch jemand im Raum?
Frau Doktor, ich habe gedacht, wir sind alleine.
Ja, ich habe das gemacht.
Ich habe das gemacht.
Allergie, ja, damals, wo ich operiert wurde,
hat man mir, wo ich Blinda-Operation hatte,
hat man mir Penicillin gegeben.
Und seitdem darf ich das nicht mehr nehmen.
Ich hatte eine Allergie gegenüber Penicillin.
Okay.
Wie ursätz ich das?
Und seit mehr weiß ich nicht, kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Und ich darf dann kein Penicillin bekommen.
Sind Sie geimpft?
Gegen Corona-Würfel und Teton?
Teton, das haben Sie gesagt, ja.
Kann ich Teton sagen?
Ja, heißt auch so.
Ja, Wunschteilkampf.
Es ist üblich, dass man auch Teton ist.
Ich habe eine Impfung gegen Wunschteilkampf.
Ja, habe ich.
Ich werde regelmäßig geimpft.
Die nächste Impfung ist in drei Jahren.
Unter Corona-Impfung bin ich geimpft.
Aber trotz der Impfung, wissen Sie, habe ich die Erkrankung
durchgemacht.
Aber das war nicht schlimm.
Das war wie eine Erkältung vor zwei Monaten.
Rauchen Sie herrschte?
Rauchen?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Sehr gut.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, nein.
Ja, bei Gelegenheit, bei Anlässen trinke ich schon mal ein Alkohol,
aber nicht regelmäßig.
Bei Gesellschaft zum Beispiel, wenn man in einer Party ist
oder bei Feiergeburtstag.
Was trinken Sie?
Bier.
In der Regel trinke ich mal Bier.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen, nein.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie das geschrieben wird.
Herr Stern, ich möchte jetzt über Ihre Familie etwas fragen.
Neben Ihre Eltern nur?
Ja.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie die heißt.
Mein Vater nimmt auch Medikament.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die heißen.
Wegen Bluthochdruck nimmt er Medikament.
Und dann hat er mal eine Herzuntersuchung gehabt.
Da haben wir einen Stand gelegt.
Herzkartite.
Und dann haben wir einen Schlauch.
Ich glaube, das hat man gelegt.
Wann wurde diese Untersuchung durchgefüllt?
Ja, mein Vater ist 78 Jahre alt.
Und das war vor zwei Jahren.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter, die ist ein Kind.
Meine Mutter hat das Problem, dass sie übergewichtig ist.
Und sie hat eine schilddrüsen Unterfunktion.
Sie nimmt auch Medikament.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt.
Und sie hat auch eine Zuckererkrankung.
Aber sie nimmt keine Medikamente ein.
Das wäre so grenzwertig mit dem Essen.
Ihr Mutter leidet Altersbedingte zu Krankheiten?
Ich weiß nicht, ob Typ 1 oder Altersbedingte.
Ich weiß, dass sie Medikament nicht nimmt.
Und dass sie durch das Essen das kontrolliert.
Sie versucht kontrolliert zu essen.
Sie hat eine bestimmte Diät.
Sie wiesen Kontrolle und das ist immer grenzwertig.
Aber das ist seit zehn Jahren so.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Geschwister? Ich habe einen Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Er ist gesund.
Er ist jünger als ich.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja.
Ich lebe mit meinem Lebensgefährten zusammen.
Wir sind nicht verheiratet.
Wir haben ein gemeinsames Kind, der ist fünf Jahre alt.
Er ist ein Sohn, der ist fünf Jahre alt.
Sie wollen mit Ihrem Partnern.
Wir sind nicht verheiratet.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Elektriker.
Herr Schikert, ich habe mich vergessen.
Haben Sie auch bemerkt, dass die Farbe der Haut geändert ist?
Wie weinen Sie das? Die Hautfarbe?
Mein Kopf wird jetzt rot.
Was weinen Sie?
Ich weine die Hautfarbe.
Ich habe eine Schwellung bemerkt.
Das ist zu dick in meinem Schlüsselbeinbereich.
Haben Sie auch bemerkt?
Nein, ich sehe das nicht.
Das ist geschwollen.
Wo mein Schlüsselbein ist, ist es dick.
Das ist mehr geschwollen als schulter.
Ich sehe kein blauen Fleck.
Ich habe alle meine Fragen gestellt.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ich möchte etwas zufügen.
Ich habe Schmerzen.
Wie geht es weiter?
Als Erster haben wir drei Schritte.
Wir haben eine richtige Diagnose gestellt.
Wir haben nur das Anamnese-Gespräch geführt.
Die zweite Schritte ist die körpallische Unterzuse.
Dann ist es eine Apparativ- und Diagnostik.
Was ist das?
Bei Ihnen ist eine Röntgenaufnahme noch wichtig.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf eine Schlüsselbeingruppe.
Wir haben dashhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
Es muss bestätigt werden.
Ja.
Und...
Ist es schlimm, Frau Doktor? Muss man operiert werden, wenn da ein Bruch ist, wenn Sie einen Bruch denken?
Ja.
Es muss operiert werden. Ja. Ja, aber...
Okay.
Das kommt auch an, welcher Bruch es ist.
Sie wollen zum Beispiel mein Bruch...
Wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden habe, wollen Sie erstmal körperlich untersuchen,
eine Rentneruntersuchung machen.
Ja.
Und dann wollen Sie gucken, was man überhaupt hat.
Und dann kann man, falls ich vielleicht kein Doktor habe,
etwas anderes machen.
Okay.
Ich werde mit meinem Oberast sprechen.
Dann...
Ich werde Sie untersuchen, körperlich untersuchen.
Ja.
Und ich werde Ihnen erzählen, wie wir weiter folgen.
Also zuerst wollen Sie mit dem Oberast sprechen und dann untersuchen.
Ja.
Als ich jetzt die Reihenfolge habe, habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Ich werde jetzt Sie körperlich untersuchen,
Danach bei Ihnen Brut abnehmen.
Und Danach werde ich mit meinem Oberast sprechen.
Wie wir weiter folgen.
Und nach dem Oberast besprechen, wollen Sie dann röntgen?
Ja.
Ich arbeite noch nicht.
Und diese Schritte.
Ich bin ein bisschen durcheinander.
Kein Problem.
Deswegen bin ich da.
Ja.
Das ist ein Test sozusagen.
Kein Problem.
Alles gut.
Ja.
Lieber hier dich richtig können als in der Realität in der Prüfung.
Okay.
Das ist das erste Mal.
Die Gruppe.
Ja, die Kollegen haben...
Ah, Sie haben auch Kollegen...
Wie weit dragon wurde geschrieben?
23 Minuten gedauert hat...
Hat es gedauert?
Ja, hat es gedauert.
22 Minuten.
Okay.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen? Eine Kollegen Frage.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Sind Sie eher dünn, dürkend, pulsierend?
Ja, ja.
Also ich kann es sich beschreiben. Das ist einfach ein Schmerz, wenn ich meinen Arm bewege.
Ich kann nicht sagen, dass es pochend oder zierend.
Wenn ich nicht viel mache, tut es nicht viel weh. Nur wenn ich mich bewegen will.
Okay, sonst habe ich vielleicht ein Druckgefühl, würde ich vielleicht sagen, wenn ich nichts mache.
Vielen Dank. Wenn Sie sich vielleicht erinnern, gab es Operationen, Komplikationen auftreten?
Wie nochmal? Fragen Sie nochmal.
Gab es Operationen?
Früher meint sie.
Ja, früher.
Es gab ja eine Operation.
Und dann gab es Komplikationen auftreten?
Ja, damals war die Komplikation gewesen mit dem Penicillin. Da habe ich allergisch reagiert.
Okay, sonst war alles normal gewesen.
Sind Sie Bluttransition erhalten?
Ein Was?
Bluttransition erhalten.
Aber haben Sie Bluttransition erhalten? Nein, habe ich nicht erhalten bis jetzt.
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Irgendwelche Schmerzen, jetzt momentan aktuell Bauchschmerzen, Kufschmerzen.
In anderen Körperregionen? Ja.
Dann habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Ich habe ein leichtes, brennendes Gefühl an meiner Schirpfunde, an der rechten Hand und einen rechten Kniegelenk.
Ich habe auch eine kleine Wunde. Die brennte ein bisschen, aber ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Nach dem Anfall haben Sie Stuhlabbeinwärts-Rassen gehn?
Nach dem Anfall?
Nach dem Anfall oder Unfall?
Unfall. Anfall ist, wenn ich Krampf- oder Lach-Anfall bekomme.
Einmal Stuhlgang oder Wasser lassen?
Nein, ich muss Sie jetzt nicht bis jetzt Stuhlgang machen.
Ich habe keine Probleme damit, aber ich habe auch keinen Bedürfnis dafür.
Nicht, dass ich wüsste, dass ich Probleme habe.
Weitere Fragen noch vielleicht?
Ich habe eine Verstellung an Ihrem Schulter oder Schlüsselbeinwärts.
Oder während der Unfall einen Knarschen gehört?
Nein, das war alles so schnell. Ich war zack, zack auf dem Boden.
Ich habe nicht gehört.
Ich meine eigentlich Stellung. Haben Sie bemerkt?
Fehlstellung, weiß ich nicht, ob das viel wird. Ich weiß nur, dass es dort geschwollen ist.
Okay, danke.
Weitere Fragen?
Haben Sie Ihren Kopf gestoßen?
Kopf gestoßen, nein.
Ich hatte auch einen Helm gehabt, aber der ist auch keine Kratzer.
Mein Helm ist auch in Ordnung. Mein Kopf wurde nicht gestoßen auf dem Boden.
Aber dafür mein Hand und mein richtig knie.
Das hat auf dem Boden gestoßen.
Ich bin hingefallen auf meine rechte Hand und der richtig knie.
Waren Sie zur Arbeit unterwegs?
Gott sei Dank habe ich noch auf zwei Wochen Urlaub.
Das war kein Wegeunfall.
Nein, mein Urlaub ist jetzt hinten.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Spindelik?
Spindlichkeit und Unfall habe ich nicht.
Vielleicht können wir das auch fragen.
Haben Sie Durchstieg?
Durchstieg, ja.
Sind Sie durstig?
Sind Sie durstig, wollen Sie fragen?
Ob ich Wasser trinken möchte?
Sind Sie nicht hapenlos?
Die Blutung können so etwas passieren.
Eine starke Blutung können etwas durchstieg sein.
Ich habe das nicht vergessen.
Haben Sie Bemerk, dass die Hose ungewöld?
Das hat gelassen.
Das Nass wurde unkontrolliert.
Nein, man kann auch sagen, haben Sie einen unkontrollierten Wasser
lassen gehabt?
Nein, okay.
Falls keine weitere Fragen sind, gleich eine Ergänzung für Sie,
Kollegen.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
in der Unfallchirurgie sind die nebensächlichen Fragen
wie die Allgemeine Anamnese
und Vorerkrankungen und Medikamente.
Es ist wichtig, aber nicht primär.
Mehr ist die spezielle Anamnese.
In der speziellen Anamnese
ist einmal der Unfall hergegangen.
Das haben Sie gefragt.
Aber z.B. was gefehlt hat, ob ich eine Lebenserscheinung habe,
Kraftlosverlust habe.
Vielleicht haben Sie das mit Farbe sagen wollen,
aber da habe ich nicht verstanden, ob die Farbe
meiner Hand oder im Verletzungsbereich.
Die wollte die Rötung bragen.
Ich versuche es noch einmal aufzubauen,
dass man ein System hat.
Man hat immer einen
guten Utopäte,
deswegen macht er weniger Fehler.
Wenn man immer dasselbe macht,
wie Sie begonnen haben,
dann sind Sie hergekommen.
Genau so.
Bei der speziellen Anamnese
würde ich gucken,
ob Sie alle Fragen einnehmen.
Wenn ein Trauma ist,
haben Sie ein Helb angehabt.
Man kann fragen,
wie auch in der Runde gesagt,
ich sage jetzt etwas, was nicht gesagt wurde.
Ich will nur ein System.
Es ist wichtig,
ob ich eine Retrograde oder eine Anamnese
habe.
Ob ich auf meinen Kopf gestoßen habe,
ist der Helm ganz...
Man kann erinnert,
aber der Helm ist kaputt.
Man hat vielleicht auch ein Trauma gehabt.
Aber wenn der Helm in Ordnung ist
und keine Kratzer hat,
dann haben Sie die Anamnese vorbei.
Dann botet es am meisten weh.
Schulterbereich, Region,
das kann alles möglich sein.
Ab dann würde ich dann ein System fragen,
wie in der Regel im Körper
es sei denn, es ist ein stumpfer Bauchtrauma
oder ein Torachstrauma.
Da kann man jetzt nicht direkt sagen,
aber da sind die Extremitäten nebensächlich.
Da gibt es andere Sachen.
Aber wenn es um Extremitätenverletzungen geht,
wie jetzt,
dann würde ich immer dieses System machen.
So mache ich das bei mir.
Nach dem Periphera durch Blutung, Motorisensibilität,
PDMS, das ist für mich ein Anhaltspunkt.
Daher würde ich dann sagen,
P heißt Periphera, dann D,
durch Blutung Untersuchungsschichtung kann ich einen Puls tasten.
Aber das ist ja eine Anamnese.
An Anamnese kann man höchstens, denke ich, fragen,
haben Sie zwischen den oberen Extremitäten
rechter Arm, linker Arm Temperatur-Unterschied bemerkt?
Kann ein Himmelssandasler,
eine Thrombose oder Atelierleverschluss ist?
Irgendwas.
Ist der ganze Arm dick geschwollen blau?
Also zu ja nottisch oder so?
Das ist ja eine Anamnese.
Durch Blutung, Motorik,
er hat ja gesagt, er kann den Arm bewegen.
Man kann ja ein bisschen genauer fragen,
wie weit können Sie den Oberarm oder den Unterarm
oder Ihre Hand oder Ihre Finger bewegen?
Sind die alle, sind die alles Gelenke?
Der würde sagen, ja, ich kann alles bewegen.
Man kann auch fragen, haben Sie Kraftverlust?
Dann würde er vielleicht sagen, ja,
dann kann man noch spezieller fragen,
ist dieser Kraftblutverlust schmerzbedingt oder nicht?
Weil wenn ich Schmerzen habe, habe ich sowieso keine Kraft.
Dann ist es keine Parise, da ist Kraftverlust durch Schmerzen.
Aber wenn Kraftverlust da ist
und er sagt, nee, ich habe aber auch keinen Schmerz,
aber trotzdem kann ich Ihre Hand nicht festhalten,
könnte Ihre Hand nicht festhalten.
Dann gibt man vielleicht eine Parise,
vielleicht eine Nervenverletzung oder ein Peripher
oder irgendwo zentral, Peripher, irgendwas.
Also, Motorik und Sensibilität,
das haben Sie gefragt, Hauptheitsgefühl,
Schmerzen, wo ziehen die hin?
Manche können es nicht beschreiben, wie der Schmerz ist
oder ziehend oder des Total-Twe, sagen einige.
Oder der andere beschreibt,
dass Sie den Arm rein oder ist unterschiedlich.
Also, Sensibilität, also, was da noch.
Und dann, wenn das vorbei ist,
würde ich dann weiter, haben Sie weitere Verletzungen
im Körper fragen.
Ja, ich habe eine oder Wunden am Körper stürzt,
kann man sich ja irgendwie verletzen mit der Haut.
Ja, ich habe eine Schürpfunde in der rechten Hand.
Kann man vielleicht fragen,
sieht Ihre Wunde sauber aus,
sind da Steinchen drin oder nicht, zum Beispiel?
Ja, nee, das ist sauber, ist eine kleine Wunde,
sieht okay aus.
Er hat eine Schürpfunde im Knie,
er hat gesagt, dass er laufen kann, aufstehen kann
und so weiter, Schmerz hat er nicht.
Man kann auch dort sagen,
Blutstütz auf der Wunde oder ist es eine tiefe Wunde,
Schürpfunden können tief sein, nicht tief sein,
oberflächlich sein.
Es brennt Körper wie Steinchen, kann man auch im Kniegelenk fragen.
Nein, es ist nicht, das ist nur eine leichte Schürpfunde.
Es brennt nur ein bisschen, das wäre die Antwort.
Haben Sie weitere körperliche Verletzungen?
Haben Sie Atemprobleme,
vielleicht Torax, was hat jemand gefragt in der Gruppe, glaube ich?
Haben Sie Atemprobleme?
Haben Sie das Gefühl,
dass Sie Schmerzen im Bereich des Bauchges haben?
Können Sie mir das sagen, dann sagt er,
alles ist gut, die anderen Examintheden auch gut.
Hilftgelenk, ihre Wirbelsäule,
dann sagt er, alles ist gut, dann haben Sie ziemlich alles gefragt.
Kopf, Haltswirbelsäule, Examinthed,
den Body, Bauch, Torax,
Beckenbereich,
da hat er keinen Hilfsgelenksschmerz oder irgendwas.
Dann denkt man, okay, dann habe ich alles gefragt.
Dann kann man dann,
dann kann man dann,
das, was Sie in der ganzen Gruppe danach fragen.
Dann möchte ich jetzt
die weiteren Angaben von Ihnen haben.
Manchmal kann einer fragen, warum Sie es haben.
Ich habe doch nur ein Schmerz,
warum wollen Sie das alles wissen, ob ich geraucht habe
oder nicht, oder kann man ja sagen, als Antwort.
Wenn jemand so schräg fragt, wie ich,
dann kann man sagen zum Beispiel, ja, ich möchte das alles aufnehmen.
Falls es zu einem Stadtstättern aufnahme kommt,
möchte ich, wie Sie als kompletter Mensch sehen
und falls es zu einer Operation kommt,
kommen sollte, wissen wir ja noch nicht.
Deswegen möchte ich auch Ihre Nebenerkrankung vielleicht,
ich kann dort etwas erkennen,
als Gesamtbild.
Deswegen möchte ich alles einzeln fragen.
Wenn alles gut ist, dann müssen Sie nicht dazu nachaufgenommen werden,
aber wenn etwas zu reden ist, dann haben wir alles gefragt,
ob Sie alle gehen haben oder dass ich nicht etwas vergesse.
Dann habe ich eine Aufnahmeburgen und mit dem möchte ich weiter vorfahren.
Und dann kann man wieder weiter erzählen.
Ansonsten,
wenn jemand fragt, wie geht es weiter
und ich habe ja sich irritiert,
was machen Sie zuerst oder was waren Sie danach und so weiter,
dann, ich hätte dann gesagt,
wir einfach unterbrechen und sagen,
wie geht es weiter, was ist zuerst?
Natürlich werde ich Sie erst immer die Reihenfolge,
das haben Sie eigentlich gesagt, aber müssen Sie auch durchziehen.
Erst möchte ich Sie körperlich ausführlich untersuchen.
Anschließend, wenn es nötig ist, ich denke ja,
aber ich denke auch,
dass wir eine Röntgen-Bergplastik machen müsste,
ob wir einen Bruch verstellen oder nicht.
Wir haben einen Schlüsselbeinbruch sozusagen.
Aber das kann ich alles nur sagen,
wie es weitergeht, wenn ich ausführlich bin.
Ja, werde ich jetzt operiert.
Das muss ich erst mal untersuchen.
Und dann gucken und diesem Bruch, falls ein Bruch da ist,
nicht jeden Bruch, den wir sehen, muss man operieren,
werde ich mit meinem Facharzt, mit meinem Oberarzt
nochmal Sie vorstellen, mit dem Gesamtbild
und Ihnen sagen, wie es weitergeht.
An am Nese, körperliche und ausführliche körperliche Untersuchungen,
eventuell bildgebende Verfahren wie Röntgen, MRT, CT
oder irgendwas gegebenenfalls Laborabnahme.
Wenn einer fragt, warum nehmen Sie Labor ab?
Falls es zu einer Operation kommen sollte
oder irgendwas auffälliges im Labor ist,
weswegen wir deswegen auch ein Labor aufnehmen,
dann würde ich das auch in der Hand nehmen.
Wenn alles gut ist, dann lieber mache ich eine Arbeit mehr,
ausführlich oder kann man so erklären.
So würde ich das sagen.
Was noch, dann,
bildgebende Verfahren,
ich habe jetzt nicht weitergemacht.
Ich hätte sagen können, muss man Röntgen,
ist das Röntgenstall gefährlich,
ich habe Angst vor Röntgenstallen,
muss man das ausführlich erklären.
Nein, die Röntgenstallen sind nicht gefährlich.
Es gibt immer einen Rest dieser Koalitionskonditionen.
Aber ich denke nicht, dass man das immer fragt, weiß ich nicht,
wie es eine Prüfung ist.
Aber ich würde immer, wenn jemand fragt, wie es jetzt weitergeht,
immer zurückbringen und dann sagen,
ja, ich verstehe Sie, Sie müssen ein bisschen Geduld haben.
Ich werde Sie erst körperliche Untersuchungen,
dann muss ich dann Diagnostik machen.
Erst dann kann man sagen, es ist etwas gebrochen,
vielleicht ist nichts gebrochen, vielleicht ist nur ein Blutergust dort.
Sie haben kein Bruch, ein bisschen Kühen, Schuhen und so weiter.
Und dann jemand fragt,
was für eine Therapie zum Beispiel wird gemacht.
Es kommt immer darauf an, wie das Gesamtergebnis ist.
Wenn es zu einem Verschub,
wenn es zu einem Bruch kommt, muss man das entweder rülkstellen,
operieren oder nicht.
Das hängt davon ab, wie disloziert gefragt wird.
Das ist die nächste, das brauche ich nicht zu sagen.
Therapie machen wir später.
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte Ihnen über einen neuen Patienten berichten.
Herr Peterstein ist ein 45-jähriger Patient.
Er ist 1,85 m groß und wiegt 78 kg.
Er stellt sich,
seit heute Morgen bestehender
Schmerz
auf einer Schmerz von 1,5 bis 2,7 l.
Besonders beim Hochheben auf der Straße.
Ich würde zurückgehen nochmal,
weil ich hatte eine Sattelkohle.
Ich habe keine Sattelkohle, ich habe keine Sattelkohle.
Er stellt sich, seit heute Morgen bestehender Schmerz
im Bereich rechten Schultergelenk.
Er stellt sich vor.
Vor haben Sie nicht gesagt.
Ja, ja, vor, wie Schmerz seinen Infolge eines Fahrradunfalls aufgetreten.
Er berichtete beim Fahrradfahren, wie Kontrolle verloren haben.
Welche Kontrolle?
Er sei ausgerutscht.
Er sei ausgerutscht und habe die Kontrolle verloren.
Der Patient war auf der Seite hingefallen.
Er klagte der Patient über Schulbunde.
Er hat die Handfläche und die Knie.
Wo rechte?
Rechte Knie.
Rechte Handfläche.
Hand innenfläche.
Die Bewegungsschwellung in den betroffenen Bereich wurde bejaht.
Die Frage wurde verneint.
Die vegetative Anämnese war unaufwendig.
Er erinnerte sich auf die Herz-Rhythmische Störung seit zwei Jahren.
Er nahm 5 mg eine Morgens.
Der Patient wurde im Alter von 10 geöffnet.
Er hat eine Erlegerung.
Er hat eine Latterale Klaviklarfraktur.